up Tony Snell certainly doing his part
McDermott oh Doug McDermott with the
flush
what
didn't see that one coming no no no I
think this is the year that I played
with D Wade and between him and Rondo
somebody said something crazy
James and Butler throwing Haymakers at
each other Butler drives and he's fouled
and Butler right now is exhausted with
46.7 remaining he's got two free throws
to give the Healer and Dwyane Wade we're
seeing having some fun on the bench or
as Gustavo Vega put it on Twitter when
you're trying to hook up your boy with
girls at the club however
and everybody's staring at him in the
Baseline
man that's going to be the fourth foul
of the game on Deontay Davis
think of the Raptor so far
Miami it's a rap for media day as you
can see I'm doing my strawberries mom
training camp back to work yeah
stay tuned please stay tuned we got
something special coming
[Music]
on the phone okay it's right because I
know you work remember that
I saw you doing young fellas
yo mama what's up boy you see me I'm
putting on for the phone on phone man
your mouth hero
tag me on the ground
put me in your Ticky top back on Butler
oh Jimmy
put a shoulder into the chest of Warren
and then Warren just got himself tossed
out of the game for Taunton
well neither player showing much of the
way of boys right there
oh my and what's gonna happen I don't
know if you saw that on TV or not the TJ
Warren that is a No-No my friend blowing
of the kiss
he's not he's not even in my open League
like nowhere near me
um and if if I was their coach I would I
would never put him on me ever again
he's like no put somebody else on me
because I'm I'm a test every time
he he really picked it up in a big way
for Miami here with bam out with Kyle
Lowry out Not only was he scoring the
ball he had to act as a playmaker too
and he did a really nice job of both
rewarding really smart defense there in
my opinion by Jimmy Butler Jimmy
obviously isn't too happy either
look at that face and this is Jimmy
Butler staring at Julius Randle when he
went to the free throwing like what are
you doing he has been Unstoppable
watch is it starting to flare here Jimmy
uh having a little fun with it
[Applause]
was going back and forth there and had
to be separated as Jimmy goes
adding little salt and pepper
oh man you like my son
yeah yeah
there you go
Williams and look at the words already
Williams and Jimmy Butler is smiling
about it and then here's the contact at
the ensuing play
and let's go head to head guys
thank you I agree I put his head down
against Grant Williams and got all the
way to the cup
[Music]
s and he's pointing at Grant Williams
from the ground that's the rest there's
the contact let me just get it up on the
glass his prayer is answered but more
importantly
Grant Williams can't believe it you're
going to pick up his second personal
foul and that's clearly a foul the
Celtics complaining that one knee with
the time outside gave this is knocking
down his third three here Jimmy Butler
Moon walks back to half court what does
he do
[Music]
we're sitting here now having defeated
the number one seed getting ready for
National Television at Madison Square
Garden on Saturday
don't we play on Sunday
I'm sorry look at you do your job thank
you I'm a hater man I don't think you
want to ask me that I am a hater so I
would just leave it at the Randall's
just mauling and appalling them that
time sometimes you see that when when
nobody has nobody has real possession
they let it go this time that Butler
didn't do it he got it right
thank you
surprise parents over me
[Applause]
what did you want Tyler to know from
this crowd from his teammates about the
toughness that he showed in really his
first NBA little scuffle I want Tyler to
know his ass should have got thrown out
if I was a Revo tossed his last how dare
you
oh y'all might be owning something over
here
[Music]
[Applause]
for the rim but he also cuts and moves
well without the basketball and that's
where he can really provide a lot of
value for Miami Jimmy likes it
he's seven of ten from the field and
hits that as the shot clock expires
meanwhile LeBron James 21 points two
quarters complete here in game five the
heat try to keep their
heads down
light McQueen
[Music]
tough play Jimmy with the step back over
the 6-4 Grayson Allen nothing but net he
is confident look at that faced by Jimmy
give me that
four on the clock thornwell from
downtown
Gibson with the rebound and with that
rebound Taj Gibson already with a double
double of 14 points once again putting
the heat on his back and carrying him
what do you think your new hair doing
your dreads and extensions are going to
do for your look and how you are
performing on the court I don't have any
extensions I don't know what you're
talking about
I don't know
uh it's still up to debate if I'm gonna
keep my hair like this or not they're
not extensions so
when you tell bam I said hello please
hey Dan uh Jack said get the hell out
the screen
[Music]
he did I did not I assume that's for
Juwan right there I mean you're gonna
have some words you better be able to
back them up watch this a little bit of
a screen and roll action that's a
beautiful pass by bam kind of a wrap
around
exactly
[Applause]
[Music]
I will take my shirt off but I want to
embarrass him for me
I really got next to you like this you
do have to deal with this hey man yeah
first of all first of all you could at
least wax this right here all right come
on
oh there is bad blood Brewing between
these two teams Jimmy Butler at half
court finger-pointing of the Denver
match
and we've got staff members over at the
Denver side talking to Jimmy which is
just crazy
meanwhile Marquis Morris still on his
back I sit in this chair pregame he
comes back in the locker room
and tells me to get the [__] up on my
seats guys it's a playoffs stop [__]
around
point at you I can't swim either you
can't swim oh you got Hood Tendencies
you would run with us
come on now he's doing something that is
this history and that cannot be
overlooked what he's doing well not like
that man
so rightfully pointed out he's he's
carried that team to work
[Music]
nobody's downtown walking fast
you've denied it before but it's playoff
Jimmy the thing are you ready to
it's not a thing it's not I just I just
I just be hooping get off your
anticipating Drive Jimmy
[Music]
well D Wade come on D
you might want to lay there for a while
too because now he's exhausted he is
because now he's gonna have to start
forcing shots because no one else can
score on their team right and he's the
only one so now he's going to start
hunting for shots to try to get back in
this ball game here's the foul by
holiday
yeah body down low
[Applause]
right next to a Legend baby
running next to a legend what's up baby